[Música]
mi nombre es carolina soy portuguesa y
soy autista no me gusta el nombre
carolina prefiero que me llamen kahui
me gustan los columpios y los tiovivos
una vez estaba columpiando es que con un
pie tanto tiempo tanto tiempo tanto
tiempo que gane una herida en la mano
pero me estaba divirtiendo tanto tanto
tanto que ni me di cuenta del desarrollo
de mi herida y me sentía el dolor
me gustan las celebraciones de esas
cuando energía entusiasmo actitud
alegría
[Aplausos]
pero me creen mucha confusión los fuegos
artificiales por su luz que es demasiada
para mis ojos y por su sonido que es
demasiado para mis oídos me gusta lavar
la vajilla en mi casa
pero no soporto el olor de la basura
a veces llego vomitando por el olor de
la basura me gusta chocar 5
pero no me gusta que me toquen sin
adaptarme porque si tocan sin na de
estarme yo siento como si me hubieran
dar un corte en la mano un puñetazo
puedo mover los tendones de la mano y
las orejas
pero no puedo tener una opción adecuada
del tiempo vamos a ver
casi todos podemos tener una noción
adecuada del tiempo pero casi nadie sabe
muy bien los tendones de la mano con las
orejas verdad
por ejemplo si yo voy a actuar en una
obra que es dentro de siete meses para
mí es como si fuera mañana el estreno y
eso me crea algo de confusión
cuando como un plato mixto como primero
toda la carne después todo el arroz y
después toda la ensalada porque porque
me hace mucha confusión la mezcla de
sabores
cuando estoy con mis compañeros es que
mis compañeros hacen mucho ruido y
hablan todos al mismo tiempo y eso para
mí es demasiada confusión y entonces me
tengo que bajar
para calmarme del estrés con que me
quedo con mis colegas
cuando estoy en una conversación estoy
lista para dar mi opinión sobre el tema
pero alguien más rápido que yo ya cambio
de tema
no puedo ya no puedo hablar
los niños con autismo tenemos estas
cositas que nos impiden de hacer amigos
más fácilmente que vosotros y con lo
difícil que es la sociedad es casi
imposible para mí de hacer amigos y por
eso cuando tenía nueve años
he creado unas amigas imaginarias jugaba
con ellas dormía con ellas obligaba a mi
mamá a darle su cabello
y cuando teníamos que cenar poníamos dos
platos más en la mesa para de servir la
cena
porque claro esas amigas para mí era lo
ideal es porque me entendían y sabían
cómo me sentía y eso es lo que hacen los
amigos reales
de hecho
no hablo con ellas hace un montón
porque ahora tengo amigos reales
[Aplausos]
pero aunque tenga amigos reales todavía
hay personas que no entienden cómo puede
ser que yo con 19 años todavía me guste
jugar con dos muñecas barbies y hasta
unicornios pero si es lo que me gusta y
además las muñecas me permiten imaginar
las muñecas me permiten crear personajes
y crear historias y a mí me encanta
imaginar crear personajes y crear
historias y por eso estoy estudiando
para ser actriz profesional
y miren
cuando estoy en el parque
nadie me juzga por tener 19 años y
estaba jugando con unicornios
claro por ejemplo si estoy interpretando
alicia en el país de las maravillas'
fíjense alicia tiene siete años y medio
y yo 19 y nadie me juzga se interpretó
alicia por tener 19 años porque porque
las personas se están permitiendo sentir
y vivir y ponerlas sus emociones en la
historia y entonces no tienen tiempo
para criticar el físico que es lo que
menos importa
vamos a ver y entonces por qué no lo
hacen en la vida real si lo pueden hacer
en un parque porque no lo hacen en la
vida real
la vida tiene sentido si nos permitimos
sentir y una cosa que yo siento del
corazón es una gran atracción por
mujeres
si estoy hablando del amor cuando veo la
mujer siento mariposas en la barriga
nunca me apasionaron por un hombre pero
hay personas que no entienden eso hay
personas que me juzgan por eso pero que
importa si es mujer con mujer hombre con
hombre o si es hombre con mujer
[Aplausos]
lo importante es sentir lo importante es
amar
[Aplausos]
cada uno de vosotros podéis vivir una
vida que os haga feliz es una vida que
os entusiasme no permitáis que lo que
los otros piensan de vosotros os impida
de vivir una vida que os entusiasme no
permitáis que lo que los otros critican
de vosotros os impida
[Música]
de ser verdaderamente felices de vivir
en mayo escolar
[Aplausos]